[Music]  well brian knew at 11 o'clock was a  stray dog the victim of a painful  accident or a brutal crime  north las vegas animal control is  investigating how it suffered  life-threatening burns the injuries so  horrible we can barely show some of the  photos on tv  tyson as he's been named was brought to  the animal foundation earlier this month  no caller no microchip no owner the  rescue group a home for spot  gathered up the money for his medical  care his painful journey striking accord  with people  across the world i've had people call me  like girl men call me and crying on the  phone because they just could not  believe  what they saw and it touched them you  know i have people from australia  you know i have people from all over the  united states called and  donated to this dog tyson's treatment is  so  intense he needs to be sedated every day  in order to clean and dress his wounds  but  his future is looking brighter there are  already people  applying to adopt him